intentan rescatar las pertenencias que
se salvaron de las inundaciones en
Italia los desbordamientos que afectan
La Norteña zona de Emilia romaña han
provocado la pérdida material de
millones de dólares el retroceso de las
aguas en algunas zonas de kuavista una
Estela de destrucción y lodo
la primera impresión fue Simplemente
terrible como se acabaran de tirar toda
esa suciedad todo ese barro fue terrible
de ver se han arruinado bastante las
cosas pero tenemos que seguir adelante
entre los damnificados se encuentra
Rafaela llora por el destino final de
sus posesiones Y algunos recuerdos
familiares perdidos en especial su álbum
de bodas
cómo es posible Tener esto así
con el paso de los días la cifra de
fallecidos aumenta sin embargo la
esperanza no perece para algunos
afectados
es importante que nadie haya resultado
herido gozamos de buena salud
trabajaremos duro y esperamos seguir
adelante
según las autoridades miles de personas
fueron evacuadas esta semana ante los
deslizamientos de tierra y el desborde
de unos 23 Ríos
todo sucedió abruptamente estábamos
preparados con barricadas y todo pero
esta solo tenían 40 centímetros de alto
tan solo 5 minutos después el agua subió
a 50 centímetros y entró a las casas
Mientras tanto los rescates continúan en
las zonas inundadas
Esta es la segunda vez en el mes que
Emilia romaña se ve afectada por las
precipitaciones en respuesta el gobierno
italiano destinará unos 30 millones de
euros en ayudas